C'est la base de notre travail.
Je suis spécialisée dans la sensibilisation du public.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Un autre mot de jargon.
Cela signifie que je conçois des campagnes d'information
afin que les candidats et les électeurs
qui n'ont jamais eu l'opportunité de participer ou de voter
comprennent où, quand et comment s'inscrire ;
où, quand et comment voter ;
et pourquoi il est important de participer.
Par exemple, j’élabore des campagnes spécifiques pour atteindre les femmes
pour faire en sorte qu'elles participent,
qu'elles fassent partie du processus.
Il en va de même pour les jeunes.
Pour tout le monde. Même les personnes handicapées.
On essaye d'atteindre tout le monde.
Cela n'est pas facile car, souvent dans ce travail,
je l'ai remarqué au fil des années,
les mots manquent.
Et alors, que faire ?
Par exemple, l'Afghanistan.
C'est un pays avec un taux d'alphabétisation faible
et le problème était, c'était en 2005,
nous avons organisé deux élections le même jour.
La raison en était que la logistique était incroyablement complexe,
Et c’était plus efficace de faire comme cela.
Certes,
mais, d'un autre côté, expliquer qu’il y avait deux élections au lieu d'une
était encore plus compliqué.
Nous avons utilisé beaucoup d'images
et le jour du scrutin,
nous avons eu des problèmes car trop de gens voulaient participer.
Nous avions 300 candidats pour 52 sièges
à la Wolesi Jirga, les élections parlementaires.
Pour le conseil provincial, nous avions encore plus de candidats.
Nous en avions 330 pour 54 sièges.
A propos de conception de bulletins de vote,
voici ce à quoi ils ressemblaient.
C'est la taille d'un journal.
C'était le bulletin de la Wolesi Jirga --
(Rires)
oui, et...
celui-ci était le bulletin du conseil provincial.
Encore plus grand.
Vous voyez que nous avons utilisé beaucoup de symboles.
Nous avons eu d'autres problèmes au Sud-Soudan.
Au Sud-Soudan, ce fut une tout autre histoire.
Nous avions tant de personnes qui, bien sûr, n'avaient jamais voté
mais nous avions un taux d'alphabétisation très faible
et de très pauvres infrastructures.
Par exemple -- c'est un pays qui fait plus ou moins la taille du Texas.
Nous avions 7 kilomètres de routes pavées,
7 kilomètres dans tout le pays,
y compris le tarmac sur lequel les avions atterrissaient
à l'aéroport de Juba.
Le transport de matériel électoral
était extrêmement difficile.
Les gens ignoraient à quoi ressemblait une urne.
C'était très compliqué,
alors, bien sûr, nous devions utiliser la communication verbale
mais il y avait 132 langues.
C'était un énorme défi.
Puis je suis arrivée en Tunisie en 2011.
C'était le Printemps Arabe.
Beaucoup d'espoir était généré par cet énorme mouvement
qui se déroulait dans la région.
Il y avait la Libye, l’Égypte, le Yémen.
C'était un moment historique très, très important.
J'étais avec la commission électorale,
nous parlions de différents aspects de l'élection,
j'entendais qu'ils utilisaient des mots que je n'avais jamais entendus.
J'avais travaillé avec les Irakiens, les Jordaniens, les Égyptiens
et, soudainement, ils utilisaient ces mots
et je me suis dit que c'était étrange.
Ce qui a suscité cette impression était le mot « observateur ».
Nous parlions des observateurs électoraux
et le commissaire de l'élection parlait de « mulahiz » en arabe.
Cela signifie « remarquer » dans un sens passif,
par exemple : « J'ai remarqué qu'il porte une chemise bleu clair. »
Est-ce que j'ai vérifié que la chemise était bleu clair ?
C'est le rôle d'un observateur d'électoral.
C'est très actif et régi par tous un tas de traités,
cela inclut une fonction de contrôle.
Puis j'ai entendu dire qu'en Égypte,
ils utilisaient le terme « mutabi’ », qui signifie « suivre ».
Nous avions maintenant des suiveurs d'élection.
Ce n'est pas exact non plus
car il y a un terme déjà accepté et en usage
qui était le mot « muraqib » qui signifie « contrôleur ».
Il contient cette notion de contrôle.
J'ai pensé que trois mots pour un concept, ce n'était pas bon.
Avec mes collègues, nous pensions que c'était peut-être notre rôle
de nous assurer que les mots étaient compris
et de créer un ouvrage de référence
pouvant être utilisé dans toute la région arabe.
C'est ce qu'on a fait.
Avec ces collègues,
nous avons lancé « le lexique arabe de terminologie électorale »
et nous avons travaillé dans huit pays différents.
Nous avons finalement défini 481 termes
qui forment la base de tout ce qu’il faut savoir
pour organiser une élection démocratique.
Nous avons défini ces termes,
avons travaillé avec des collègues arabes
et sommes parvenus à un accord sur le mot dont l'usage
serait approprié en arabe.
Le problème était en partie la richesse de la langue arabe.
Mais il y a 22 pays qui parlent arabe
et ils utilisent l'arabe standard moderne
qui est l'arabe utilisé dans toute la région,
dans les journaux et les émissions,
mais, bien sûr, d'un pays à l'autre,
la langue et son utilisation quotidienne varient,
selon les dialectes, les expressions courantes, etc.
Cela rendait la tâche complexe.
Dans un sens, il y avait le problème
que le langage n'était pas complètement mûr, si on veut,
des néologismes et expressions faisaient leur apparition.
Nous avons défini tous ces termes
puis nous avons identifié huit correspondants dans la région.
Nous leur avons soumis le brouillon,
ils nous ont répondu :
« Oui, nous comprenons la définition.
Et nous sommes d'accord
mais voici ce que nous disons dans notre pays. »
Car nous n'allions pas harmoniser ou forcer l'harmonisation.
Nous essayions de faciliter la compréhension entre les gens.
En jaune, vous voyez les différentes expressions utilisées
dans les différents pays.
Je suis heureuse de le dire, ce lexique a pris trois ans à produire
car nous avons finalisé le brouillon, l'avons apporté sur place,
avons discuté avec les commissions électorales
de ces différents pays,
avons débattu et raffiné le brouillon
puis l'avons finalement publié en novembre 2014 au Caire.
L’ouvrage est bien diffusé, nous avons publié 10 000 exemplaires.
A ce jour, il y a eu environ 3 000 téléchargements du PDF sur internet.
Un collègue m'a dit récemment que le lexique s’exporte en Somalie.
Ils vont en produire une version en somalien
car il n'y a rien du tout en Somalie.
C'est bon à savoir.
Et la nouvelle Association Arabe des Organisations de Gestion Électorale,
qui a pour but de professionnaliser
la gestion des élections dans la région,
l'utilise également.
La Ligue Arabe a mis en place une unité d'observation électorale pan-arabe
qui l'utilise également.
C'est aussi très bien.
Cependant, cet ouvrage de référence est d'un niveau assez élevé.
Il est complexe et beaucoup de termes sont assez techniques,
une personne ordinaire n'a probablement besoin d'en connaître que les deux tiers.
Les habitants du Moyen-Orient
ont été privés de toute forme de ce que nous appelons éducation civique.
Cela fait partie de notre éducation scolaire.
Cela n'existe pas vraiment dans cette partie du monde
et j'ai le sentiment que chacun a le droit
de savoir comment ces choses fonctionnent.
Ce serait bien de penser à produire un ouvrage de référence
pour le citoyen normal.
Il faut dire que maintenant,
nous avons une base de travail,
mais nous avons aussi la technologie,
nous pouvons toucher les gens via des applications téléphoniques,
avec des vidéos, des animations.
Toutes sortes d'outils peuvent être utilisés
pour communiquer ces idées à la population
pour la première fois dans leur propre langue.
Nous entendons beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles sur le Moyen-Orient,
le chaos de la guerre, le terrorisme,
le sectarisme et toutes ces horribles nouvelles négatives
qui nous parviennent constamment.
Mais ce que nous n'entendons pas, c’est ce que pensent les gens ordinaires.
A quoi aspirent-ils ?
Donnons-leur les moyens, donnons-leur les mots.
La majorité silencieuse est silencieuse
car elle n'a pas les mots.
La majorité silencieuse a besoin de savoir.
Il est temps de fournir aux gens les outils de connaissance
avec lesquels ils peuvent s'informer.
La majorité silencieuse n'a pas à être silencieuse.
Aidons-les à avoir une voix.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)